enbw still operates two nuclear power
plants this is one of them
but they'll both be decommissioned by
2022 at the latest
at that time energy generation will be
moved offshore
this is the man behind the change
my off guard is with my team my job is
to work with my team to set a course and
to ensure we stay on it
i see myself as worker number one i
speak with colleagues reach an
understanding then we go forward and
work together to implement that
a dream job
a first-class job
the energy company ceo is given an
exclusive interview to dw's made in
germany
twenty thousand subordinates are
counting on frank mustillo to save their
jobs
the company brought him in two and a
half years ago
you've got to live out your emotions
show for example that i'm convinced that
the changes aren't going to get me down
and that change can also be seen as an
opportunity
mustio's company is a german industrial
giant as one of the four major energy
companies it dominated the market for
electricity for years in 2003 its market
share was still 86 percent
but many smaller firms have penetrated
the market
analysts say germany's energy market has
been democratized by the government's
drive to develop and subsidize renewable
share in power generation
farmers are producing wind energy
private homes are using their roofs to
produce solar energy many small
providers are pushing prices down
by contrast the big companies are still
relying on large power plants
enbw has just built a new coal-fired
facility and caused karlsruhe for 1.3
billion euros
it went online last year
with today's electricity prices the
plant won't pay for itself
what do you think has to happen
we've got to create a system that
financially rewards providing reliable
services because the power plants are
indispensable for basic supply
and basic supply means electricity for
millions of private homes and many large
companies
enbw's traditional market is
badenfueltenberg which is where a great
deal of german industry is concentrated
there they're worried about calm cloudy
days
do companies come to you because they're
afraid of power failures
absolutely
many companies are worried about it some
take the necessary precautions and have
emergency generators
we've got business models for that
more customer friendliness and more
renewables that's what must you wants
from his workers
nuclear energy one of the firm's largest
sources of revenue is slowly being
phased out in germany
of the country's four largest energy
suppliers enbw generated more with
nuclear power than the others
it earned them billions but in 2012 it
decommissioned two plants
now only two supply power
was getting out of nuclear power
generation the right decision
also
i think they could have cushioned the
repercussions of the reliability of
supply for some measures involved in the
shift to renewables by continuing to
operate the nuclear power plants for a
certain period
as germany's largest offshore wind
energy provider it relies on the power
generated by siemens turbines
the baltic 2 wind farm is set to come
online this year
it can supply 340 000 households
how do you see it
what stage of the shift to renewables
are we in right now
a large part of the conversion is behind
us
and in the meantime we're getting about
eighty thousand megawatts from wind and
solar energy in germany that's almost as
much as the conventional generation
capacity that took over a century to
build as mastio says worker number one
has to lead his company through the
entire shift to renewables